Patricio Barragán comenzó a asistir a
prácticas Se tiró al blanco el
incremento de la criminalidad en Ecuador
y la nueva ley que permite el porte de
armas lo ha motivado a entrenarse para
estar preparado ante un eventual suceso
que ponga en riesgo su vida yo espero
nunca estar en medio de algún algún
alguno de esos eventos Pero bueno entre
todo eso prepararse no está de más
perfecto Te felicito José bastidas es un
experto en el manejo de armas tras la
medida decretada por el ejecutivo
ecuatoriano recibe centenares de
llamadas de nuevos aspirantes que
quieren aprender a disparar el decreto
exige contar con 25 años de edad no
tener antecedentes penales y denuncias
por violencia familiar y justificar la
tenencia de un arma Entonces esto
realmente ha motivado a las personas
pero también con esto la delincuencia
también va a poner en alerta
no solo los civiles están tomando la
iniciativa de Aprender a usar armas Los
vigilantes de seguridad como Miguel
también deben tener una preparación en
uso de armamento porque según la medida
gubernamental ahora serán apoyo de la
Policía Nacional si usted no utiliza
alarma le pueden salir como Cómplices no
sino que queda como un guarda ya en
epecto que no no pudo hacer bien su
trabajo algo y si lo utilizamos Claro
que tenemos podemos enfrentar cargos con
la justicia
preocupa el psiquia Fernando Cornejo el
experto asegura que los Ecuatorianos
sufren de paranoia ante el estado de
inseguridad y armarlos generaría más
violencia si se enfrentan a una eventual
reacción en defensa personal vamos a
llamarle porque es una conducta
desadaptativa en general de la población
y esto nos puede llevar a que no
tengamos los filtros suficientes para
poder generar una situación de defensa
datos oficiales señala que en el año
2021 se produjeron 1081
tes violentas en el año 2022 se
incrementó a 2.521 y en los tres
primeros meses de 2023 la Policía
Nacional ya lleva contabilizadas 1356
asesinatos